Now, I'm sure you've noticed many different areas of the brain are involved in
memory. When it comes to long term memory explicit and implicit memories are
stored in different areas. Explicit memories are taken in from the prefrontal
cortex and processed in the hippocampus. Then they're returned to the area
where the sensory information was originally processed. [INAUDIBLE]. So, for
example, your explicit visual memory would be stored in the occipital lobe,
whereas, for example, your explicit memory about the way something felt would
be stored in this sensory cortex. And the auditory memories would be stored in
the auditory cortex. Implicit memories are processed and stored in their
cortexes. As well as the straitum, amygdala, and cerebellum.